الآن بعد ما شرحنا كل عناصر VQE، هيا
نلخص ما تعلمناه ونشوف كيف ينفذه الحاسوب الكمومي.
نبدأ بالحالة المرجعية المختارة بعناية، والـ circuit ذو المعاملات،
والاختيار الأولي للمعاملات والـ Hamiltonian.
نمرر هذه للحاسوب الكمومي.
قبل ما يتم تنفيذ الـ Hamiltonian على حالة الـ ansatz،
نحتاج نعمل معالجة كلاسيكية مسبقة للـ circuit
لنجعله قابلاً للقراءة بواسطة الأجهزة الكمومية في عملية تسمى transpilation.
من المهم أيضاً الاستفادة القصوى
من معمارية الـ qubit في الأجهزة الحقيقية للحصول على أفضل النتائج.
هذه العمليات غالباً تتم تلقائياً لكي لا نضطر
لمعرفة ترابط الـ qubit بشكل صريح،
وفيدلتي الـ gate وما إلى ذلك.
الآن المهمة هي قياس الحالة الناتجة
وتقدير قيمة التوقع، التي ستُحسَّن أكثر
بواسطة مُحسِّن كلاسيكي.
يتم إجراء هذا القياس عن طريق تدوير أساس القياس
ثم دمج نتائج القياس للحصول على قيمة التوقع.
هذه النتيجة ذات المعاملات تُغذَّى بعدين
في المُحسِّن الكلاسيكي، الذي يجد معاملات جديدة للحالة.
ثم تتكرر العملية.
المعالجة الكلاسيكية المسبقة تُنشئ circuit جديداً ذا معاملات
ونطبق نفس الـ Hamiltonian كما في السابق.
لاحظ أنه في كامل عملية VQE نحن نغير الحالات فقط
عبر المعاملات التي تقترب وتقترب أكثر من الحالة الأساسية.
نكرر هذا حتى نكون راضين عن النتيجة.
وهذا كل شيء.
اسمي Victoria Lipinska وهذه كانت دورة حل القيم الذاتية الكمومية التغايري.